gedacht getan das unmögliche aus weniger
treibstoff mehr kilometer rausholen das
wird ihnen präsentiert von handel
[Musik]
lausanne hat ein drogenproblem und vor
allem ein wachsendes problem mit den
dealer aber seit gut einem jahr ist in
der stadtregierung ein neuer
sicherheitschef im amt dieser hat den
dealern den kampf angesagt
ein westschweizer filmteam hat daraufhin
die drogenpolizei zwei monate lang bei
der umsetzung der neuen strategie
begleitet und beobachtet wie man die
situation in lausanne in den griff
bekommen will
[Musik]
wie ist es möglich dass 150 afrikaner
offen auf unseren straßen dielen und
dass er drei vier jahren
luca toni ist das möglich ich verstehe
es nicht
wir sollten so oft eingreifen und müssen
so viele fälle bearbeiten
wir können unmöglich alles bewältigen
also behandeln wir die schwersten fälle
zuerst als ich jünger war dachte ich wir
könnten in lausanne etwas bewirken
seit einigen jahren weiß ich das geht
nicht
ich bin in lausanne geboren
wie alle stadtbewohner bedaure ich
natürlich dass die situation so schlimm
geworden ist auch wenn das nicht die
einzige erklärung ist aber seit dem jahr
2000 ist der kokain import explodiert
dadurch hat sich in den letzten jahren
der drogenhandel verdreifacht wir haben
aber nicht mehr polizisten zur verfügung
und den handel zu unterbinden kann den
stoff heute sehr leicht verkaufen und
die strafen sind leider zu gering um
dealer abzuschrecken
[Musik]
das betäubungsmittel dezernate polizei
usern eine streng gesicherte abteilung
hier arbeiten all jene die hinter den
dealern her sind sie dürfen nicht
erkannt werden von denen die sie jagen
zuerst observiert eine ergibt das
geschehen von einem fixen standpunkt aus
sie beobachtet wie viele personen sich
auf und um den platz aufhalten und vor
allem ob mit drogen gehandelt wird
wir beobachten von wohnungen und büros
aus und das sehr diskret sind wir immer
zu sehr präsent spricht sich das schnell
herum und wenn wir intervenieren müssen
ist niemand mehr da für diesen einsatz
wurden alle kräfte von stadt und kanton
mobilisiert fahren dar und
spezialermittler arbeiten zusammen in
der operation aus der xtra dem dritten
großeinsatz dieser art in der stadt
lausanne
die schwierigkeit ist dass wir einen
großen sektor abdecken müssen wenn es
auf dem platz losgeht werden sich
gewisse afrikaner richtung bahnhof
absetzen wollen müssen wir den fluchtweg
abschneiden und sie überprüfen alles ist
bereit für die großaktion das ziel die
dealer von der straße zu vertreiben
es geht los richtung plastron im
stadtzentrum wichtigster umschlagplatz
verschiedenster drogen ich bin mit
kollege hughes vor ort ich sehe drei
afrikaner auf der genfer seite dort gibt
es zwei transaktionen wo genau vor den
bankomaten nein auf der höhe der straße
petit roche verstanden
ich sehe den typen nicht kannst nun
beschreiben der afrikaner der schon zwei
transaktionen durchgeführt hat ist
schwarz gekleidet und trägt etwas grünes
auf dem rücken der mitte grünen kapuze
versteckt sich hinter dem
ticketautomaten nach einigen stunden
beobachtung zieht sich die schlinge zu
150 polizisten in zivil und in uniform
halten sich bereit in drei minuten gut
dort rennt einer weg legen
dort ist er
meinst du wir packen beide nicht bewegen
so bleiben
die zwei auch
eine großaktion mit allen
repressionsmittel gut sichtbar für
jedermann ist das wirklich ein schlag
gegen die dealer oder wird damit nur
sand in die augen der low seine
folgerung gestreut was ich finde es
wichtig die bevölkerung zu beruhigen und
polizei präsenz zu markieren
auch gegenüber den dealern in dieser
phase wollen wir erreichen da sind sich
ständig bedrängt wenn wir sie
kontrollieren schicken wir sie in den
kanton zurück indem sie registriert sind
das verunsichert sie sie haben nicht
mehr das gefühl tun zu können was sie
wollen
das versuchen wir zu erreichen das
resultat ein wenig marihuana etwas
kokain aber keine großen mengen 52
kontrollen 7 verhaftungen alle kommen
anderntags wieder frei
es ist gut dass wir präsenz markieren so
lassen wir diese typen spüren dass es
keinen ort gibt wo die polizei nicht
interveniert und sie unbehelligt lässt
denn momentan tun sie was sie wollen
das resultat ist zwiespältig
ich denke wenn wir morgen oder
übermorgen wieder aufkreuzen treffen wir
wieder die gleichen afrika
besonders an der operation asterix true
aber das was wir nachher taten auf der
platzierung waren wir hinterher ständig
mit dem kastenwagen präsent das zeichnet
diese operation aus wir führten nicht
nur eine razzia durch sondern
flankierten sie mit einer ständigen
polizeipräsenz hier
das hat eine präventive und sicher auch
eine repressive bildung
wir haben eine wichtige soziale
kontrollfunktion für die dealer und die
bevölkerung ich dir wo du auch müssen
wieder vermehrt uniformierte polizisten
auf der straße präsenz markieren
diesen aspekt haben wir vielleicht in
der letzten zeit etwas vernachlässigt
weil uns die mittel fehlten
darauf müssen wir nun in den nächsten
monaten und jahren fokussieren als
lösung für das zentrale problem der
unsicherheit und des gefühls das
verbrechen ungestraft bleiben
dies das credo des sicherheitschefs von
lausanne seit 2012 ist er in der
stadtregierung lausanne für diesen
bereich zuständig
[Musik]
im kampf gegen die kleindealer haben die
polizisten eine neue waffe fiktive käufe
früher waren sie nicht berechtigt auf
diese weise dealer zu überführen
da die praxis neu ist will sich der chef
der kriminalpolizei vor ort ein eigenes
bild machen
der typ in der blauen jeans hat sich
vielleicht in der seitenstraße versteckt
wo ist der schwarzer den wir am anfang
gesehen haben weiter oben in der nähe
des parks er kommt zur kreuzung momentan
ist kein schwarzer in sicht braune jacke
inspektor sie begibt sich als süchtiger
aus nicht zu weit ich sehe dich noch
zehn meter
jetzt sehe ich dich nicht mehr kommt
zurück
schwarze geht auf sap zu richtung
kreuzung rucksack ein afrikaner mit
schwarzer jacke schwarzer mütze und
heller jeans reden miteinander und gehen
richtung college ein anderer schwarzer
kommt dazu rote weste und raster luke
kopfhörer und ein bier in der hand
bieten hallo raster des tirolers damit
roter weste nimmt etwas aus der
hosentasche und gibt es der schwarzen
mütze
also müssen wir beide fest jetzt zieht
er die ware hervor
er zieht ein säckchen aus der
hosentasche und wird es gleich selbst
verkaufen
geschäft abgeschlossen sie sind bei der
kreuzung ich sehe sie geht vorsichtig
näher
ihr habt grünes licht
ein zugriff
[Musik]
hockey gespielt war nicht einfach mit
zwei leuten zu gast auf mit ihr hat den
stoff in die hosentasche gesteckt
bleib so stehen erst so gute musik aus
einem polizisten drogen bescheuert
[Musik]
die beiden kleindealer wurden in
flagranti geschnappt doch die
gefängnisse sind voll die pendenzen
stapeln sich was bringt das hauptziel
ist es die leute zu verunsichern die vom
tieren leben
sie wisse nicht mehr an wen sie den
stoff verkaufen ist es ein süchtiger
oder ein polizist wir die stabilisieren
wenn unsere leute auf einen dealer zu
gehen und ihm zu verstehen geben dass
sie stoff wollen gehen sie oft darauf
ein
erstaunt dass sie nicht so sehen wie
einfach man in ihrer stadt
nein keineswegs das erlebe ich auch wenn
ich in zivil am sonntagabend in der nähe
des bahnhofs spazieren gehe weiß ich
wenn ich mich gewissen typen nähere
wollen sie mir was anderes
deshalb wird der stau ist also einfach
in der schweiz sehr einfach und bringt
viel geld in kurzer zeit den typen habe
ich noch nie gesehen ich kenne dich
nicht sie haben mir kokain verkauft für
60 franken gut gehen sie da rein und
dann nach rechts hände aus den taschen
ihre schuhe bitte meine schuhe ja
wiederholen sie nicht immer was ich sage
ich habe gesagt geben sie mir bitte ihre
schuhe geben sie mir bitte ihre hose
meine hose ja
was soll das behandelt man in der
schweiz so die menschen sagen das ist
mein job
ich muss um 6 45 zurück sein
ich weiß nicht aber halb betrunken ist
nicht alles versteht oder die biel ist
jedenfalls ist er ziemlich stabil aber
nicht gewalttätig nein aber wirklich db
will nur in sein zentrum zurück versteht
nicht was man ihm sagt hat nie was
verkauft einfach damit co2 ist und ich
nicht nervst die beute entspricht bei
weitem nicht dem aufwand der
dreistündigen drogen jagt eine kugel
kokain
mit der handynummer bindet der dealer
den kunden an sich
so kann er jederzeit einen weiteren deal
ausmachen unter dieser nummer ist er
immer erreichbar
haben sie geld für einen anwalt
ich arbeite nicht in der schweiz gibt es
keine arbeit
meine frage ist einfach wenn sie einen
anwalt wollen müssen sie ihn bezahlen
gut
wann kommt er wenn sie nichts getan
haben warum wollen sie einen anwalt
ich verstehe nicht warum ich hier bin
wenn sie keine probleme mit der polizei
haben wollen verkaufen sie kein kokain
was ist kokain sie wissen nicht was
kokain ist kokain ist eine droge was ist
eine droge hindeuten dass wissen sie
nicht nein weiß ich nicht warum bin ich
hier nun das wissen sie genau ich
schreibe momentan will ich keinen anwalt
ich muss heute abend ins zentrum zu
rücken zeit gehen sie bitte 1
gehen sie da rein da können sie schlafen
es dauerte stunden um diesen kleindealer
zu verhaften und morgen wird er wieder
frei sein
das ist die nie endende sisyphos arbeit
der polizei weil in diesem land die
freizügig ssten gesetze europas
herrschen in frankreich italien oder
deutschland werden kleindealer viel
härter angefasst als in der schweiz
siehst du längst in schwarzen er
verkauft kokain
der schwarze in der ecke dort
der von gestern in der blauen jeans
anderntags sehen die fahnder dieselben
dealer und beginnen wieder bei null
wir versuchen sie auf frischer tat zu
ertappen
wenn jemand wie meistens kokain verkauft
erwischen wir ihn mit einer kugel
das ist weniger als ein gramm kokain
wenn wir jemanden verhaften der uns
nicht bekannt ist das heißt nicht
vorbestraft kommt er schnell wieder frei
weil über thriller die therapie musiker
wenig zu weit sie gehen die rivalen
herunter in anbetracht dieser sie fuß
arbeit den stundenlangen operation um
einen dealer zu schnappen und ihn am
nächsten tag wieder freizulassen
fragt man sich woher die drogenfahnder
ihre motivation nehmen
ich bin immer noch motiviert für das was
ich tue was man muss motiviert bleiben
und nicht zu weit in die zukunft schauen
sonst sagt man sich meine arbeit bringt
nichts aber das stimmt nicht
unsere arbeit ist nützlich auch wenn man
einen dealer 23 mal schnappen muss wenn
er weiter wild kommt er früher oder
später und das katz und maus spiel
beginnt wieder von vorne
eine fast rituelle routine man jagt ein
dealer verhaftet ihn und lässt ihn
wieder frei dieser mann wurde zum ersten
mal geschnappt mit einer kugel kokain
nach vier stunden ist er wieder frei
für außenstehende ist es natürlich
schockierend zu sehen dass man einen
mann der ein oder zwei mal drogen
verkauft sofort wieder freilässt
eines darf man nicht vergessen und das
wird oft übersehen
solche leute werden schließlich
verurteilt je mehr sie verkaufen desto
höher fällt die strafe aus meistens sind
es dir und meistens werden ihnen
gefängnisstrafen aufgebrummt die sie
absitzen müssen wenn auch erst einige
wochen oder monate nach der
gerichtsverhandlung aber sie kommen
hinter gitter mit
[Musik]
grund dafür ist die neue
strafprozessordnung die im januar 2011
verabschiedet wurde sie vereinheitlich
die strafprozesse in der schweiz was gut
ist schlecht wirkt sich hingegen aus
dass sie einen rattenschwanz von
behördengängen nach sich zieht
zum ärger der drogenfahnder denn sie
sitzen stundenlang im büro fest anstatt
vor ort sein zu können und wären sie
papierkram erledigen dielen die dealer
munter weiter es ist kein geheimnis
seit glaube ich zwei jahren haben sich
viele anwälte darüber ausgelassen
die neue strafprozessordnung bringt
unglaublich viel bürokratie und
papierkram mit sich das gab es vorher
nicht
wie bereits diskutiert habe ich ihnen
vorhin ihre rechte vorgelesen jetzt wird
man sie vernehmen wegen verletzung des
betäubungsmittelgesetzes verstanden
man stellt ihnen fragen sie müssen nicht
antworten wenn sie nicht wollen wissen
sie dass ihr asylantrag abgelehnt wurde
ja wissen sie dass sie die schweiz
verlassen müssen
ja aber dafür habe ich kein geld am 13
oktober bekamen sie den bescheid und
sind trotzdem in der schweiz geblieben
sie haben bekanntlich einem polizisten
in zivil drogen angeboten
wenig später haben sie ihm für 60
franken eine kugel kokain verkauft sie
haben ihm auch ihre handynummer gegeben
falls er nochmals drogen kaufen will
stimmt das die neue strafprozessordnung
sieht auch diese vereinfachten verhöre
vor dank ihnen können die drogenfahnder
herausfinden wer die dealer und wer ihre
kunden sind aber der richter befindet
über ihre gefängnisstrafe
und da die gerichte überlastet und die
gefängnisse überfüllt sind haben die
kleinen lila wenig zu befürchten wegen
einer kugel kokain das kokain bekam ich
üblicherweise müssen sie für so ein
vergehen hier übernachten und morgen
beim erkennungsdienst ihre
fingerabdrücke hinterlassen
dann lässt man sie vielleicht frei das
entscheide aber nicht ich das tut der
richter es gibt zwei dinge verleitet die
richter dazu solche kleindealer
freizusprechen
erstens erlaubt ihnen das gesetz nicht
so kleine vergehen strenger zu bestrafen
vor allem verstöße gegen das
betäubungsmittelgesetz sind die gerichte
überlastet und die gefängnisse überfüllt
und wie zum beispiel im kanton waadt da
ist die versuchung groß solche leute
laufen zu lassen
doch welchen schluss muss man daraus
zitieren
man könnte sagen die polizei muss
aufhören zu arbeiten ich zu diesem
schluss darf man natürlich nicht
gelangen man muss viel mehr polizeiliche
maßnahmen finden die wirksam sind und
den drogenhandel de stabilisieren
die skination abgesehen von der
bestrafungs problematik ist der
drogenhandel ein bisschen wenn er
weniger attraktiv ist hat man einen
gewissen einfluss auf den markt und die
organisation des drogenhandels in der
stadt
die dealer dylan munter weiter trotz
verfeinerter jagdmethoden der polizei
schlüpfen viele durch die maschen ihrer
fangnetze
nachts ist es noch schlimmer das paradox
die bevölkerung will dass die polizei
schärfer durchgreift tut sie das nehmen
es ihr jedoch viele übel
es gibt stadtbewohner die ziemlich
brüskiert reagieren wenn sie einen
einsatz von uns miterleben aber das ist
sehr naiv sie sehen dass sich zwei
personen am boden raufen und das steht
in brutal im gegensatz zur normalität
ihres lebens ist das viola apa
allein normalität des killers madonna
aber man muss etwas wissen
wenn die polizei beschließt jemanden
festzunehmen und ihn deshalb auf dem
boden zwingt tut sie das nicht aus spaß
oder zufällig sie geht vielmehr sehr
präzis und überlegt vor
denn die person könnte bewaffnet sein
man muss verhindern dass sie ein messer
oder eine andere waffe zückt und das
ganze eskaliert
die urlaubsstimmung kommt immer besser
die leute wollen unbedingt dass die
polizei beliebt ist das alles was wir
tun transparent ist und unsere weste
weißer als weiß kein falsches wort nicht
die kleinste unkorrekte bewegung das
alles damit uns die ganze welt
schließlich lieben wird was aber
womöglich viele vergessen wenn wir
jemanden verhaften mag der uns nicht und
im leben ist es nun mal so dass es leute
gibt die delikte begehen die romantische
vorstellung dass sich alle lieben ist
eine utopie die wir nie erleben werden
ist diese katze und maus jagt spiel
das ist kein spiel das war es als ich
zehn oder zwölf war und mit meinen
freunden räuber und gendarm spiel meine
heutige arbeit ist kein spiel
da geht es um delikte und verbrechen für
mich ist das kein spiel
auffallend ist das fast täglich
nigerianer albaner und maghrebiner
verhaftet werden
besteht da nicht die gefahr als polizist
zum rassisten zu werden
[Musik]
es ist nicht einfach mit all den
afrikanern
manchmal ist es schwer objektiv zu
bleiben und nicht alle in den gleichen
topf zu werfen
bei der festnahme eines dealers geht es
darum diese person festzunehmen
unabhängig davon
das ist mein fokus
ich versuche meine arbeit gut zu machen
und neutral zu bleiben
ich sage nicht alle afrikaner sind
dealer oder immer diese albaner und es
gibt nicht nur albaner oder maghrebiner
die heroin verkaufen
obwohl sie die mehrheit stellen darf man
nicht zu denken das ist nicht gut für
die eigene gesundheit sonst bekommt man
wagen brennen
auch wenn sie es satt haben die kleinen
dealer ständig laufen lassen zu müssen
die drogenfahnder scheinen ihre sie
fußarbeit mit humor zu nehmen
was heißt es also ein guter polizist zu
sein
ich denke die ein zahl stimmt hier nicht
denn es gibt viele sehr gute polizisten
als kopf dieser equipe brauch ich wie
ein maler eine palette mit verschiedenen
farben und ich auch verschiedene
charaktere die sich den personen
anpassen können die wir verhören müssen
der gemeinsame nenner dieser guten
polizisten ist der glaube an das was ich
erwarte auch dass sie eine gewisse
empathie haben für andere menschen ohne
naiv zu sein
das heißt die fähigkeit sich in andere
hineinversetzen zu können
die fähigkeit zu verstehen warum jemand
eines tages etwas tun kann
das gegen das gesetz verstößt ein guter
polizist muss das nicht akzeptieren aber
verstehen können akzeptieren braun
du hast keine kinder
[Musik]
es gibt den sichtbaren drogenhandel und
die unsichtbare diskrete welt der
großdealer diese zu fangen ist in
spezial ermittlern vorbehalten
ihre aufgabe das netz der dealer zu
zerschlagen
das bedingt oft monatelange ermittlungen
dank eines hinweises können wir ein
telefon abhören das einem kokain
großdealer gehört wir versuchen
herauszufinden wann und wie die ware
geliefert wird inspektor sap instruiert
seine leute vor ort ein großdealer den
sie seit monaten abhören erwartet eine
große lieferung aus den zuletzt
abgehörten gesprächen geht hervor dass
ein lieferant heute aus spanien anreist
wir werden ein greifen sobald die ware
in lusern eintrifft
ich habe eine equipe ihr und eine unten
wir werden ihn hier erwarten etwas im
hintergrund
zum glück ist dort eine tankstelle da
können wir uns versorgen und müssen
nicht verdursten
wie lange dauert so was denn wir rechnen
mit nun keine ahnung
das gehört zum job
wir wissen wann beginnt aber nicht wann
er zu ende ist t shirt mit blauer kapuze
ein massiger typ verstanden wie es
aussieht ist das nicht max ich glaube
nicht
max ist der übernahme für die zielperson
acht polizisten in zivil warten auf ihn
und kontrollieren das ganze quartier
hast du gehört eben wurde bestätigt dass
der lieferant heute kommt und unseren
max kontaktiert sobald er ein trifft
sich die lange warterei lohnt es sich in
99 prozent der fälle sind wir
erfolgreich
wir führen nicht buch über die
konfiszierten mengen in solchen
abhöraktionen im letzten fall waren es
drei kleine aber auch wenn es nur 500
gramm kokain sind diese typen müssen für
mehrere jahre ins gefängnis
also zahlt es sich schließlich aus sechs
stunden später warten sie immer noch max
los seinem lieferanten in spanien sagen
wann er seine ware bekommen hat in
diesem moment wissen wir dass er etwas
bei sich hat verstanden
ich bin es geht es gut ich bin wieder
ein fahrzeug bei fox und das andere im
bereich wie mulan für die einsatz heute
ist alles klar
es gibt gleich los ich weiß nicht wer
nicht heimkommen es schon mal und ich
halte dich auf dem laufenden
du hast deine chance man braucht eine
art jagdinstinkt den wählen mit den
vorhandenen mitteln etwas zu erreichen
die drogenfahnder konfiszieren ware und
verhaften die latte schoss max hat einen
kontakt mal angerufen und gesagt er habe
qualitativ gute ware erhalten
ich habe nicht verstanden ich denke wir
sollten nicht zu lange warten
gehen wir die pop angst ich habe keine
ahnung was ist ihre angst heißt dass man
seine handlungsfähigkeit verliert nicht
mehr weiß was man tun soll erstaunt
nein ich habe keine angst ich merke
vielleicht dass mein puls ansteigt
ich spüre den adrenalinstoß das passiert
fast jedes mal und das erlebt fast jeder
polizist beim einsatz
resultiert wohl in seinem kopf willst du
was sagen das ist nicht lustig die
spannung lässt nach und die
systematischen durchsuchung der wohnung
beginnt nach einer genau methode damit
kein potenzielles versteck übersehen
wird
jeder weiß genau was er zu tun hat alles
wird auseinandergenommen
doch zwei volle staubsauger war von der
staub und voller war
wir öffnen sie nicht sofort hier drin
sind kugeln und zehn gramm fingerlinge
da drin sind verkaufsbereiten kugeln
quartier fingerlinge die beute mehr als
400 gramm kokain bester qualität und im
labor wurden fingerabdrücke des
mutmaßlichen dealers entdeckt nun wird
untersucht wie reihen der stoff ist
davon hängt die höhe der gefängnisstrafe
ab 18 gramm reines kokain gelten als
schweres delikt bei heroin sind es zwölf
gramm
zudem gilt es herauszufinden woher die
drogen stammen
es gibt winzige partikel die bei der
herstellung abfallen
diese werden in gewissen ländern mehr
verwendet als in anderen
das erlaubt uns eine art identitätskarte
des produkts zu erstellen
dadurch können wir ermitteln wo in der
schweiz es sonst nach aufgetaucht ist
vielleicht wurden in fribourg oder st
gallen drogen vom gleichen typus
sichergestellt dann kann man
verbindungen herstellen zum beispiel im
bereich der verteilernetze dank dieser
langzeituntersuchungen konnte die loser
drogenpolizei 2012 16 grossisten netze
eruieren drei mehr als 2011
um diese drogen zu beschlagnahmen
braucht es sechs monate
es sind mehr als drei kilogramm und sie
stammen aus nigeria
diese große menge wurde auf besondere
weise transportiert die eine art drogen
zu schmuggeln vor allem aus nigeria ist
der transport im magen
in diesem fall hat der mann 84 solche
fingerlinge verschluckt wie geht man mit
einer großzügigen entschädigung sind
gewisse leute dazu bereit sofern sie
physisch dazu imstande sind denn das
ausscheiden ist mindestens so schwierig
wieder zu schlucken
das ist die größte kokain beute in der
karriere von inspector sap in der
schweiz werden jährlich vier bis fünf
tonnen kokain konsumiert die polizei
beschlagnahmt höchstens zehn prozent
davon vor einigen jahren hatten wir den
eindruck beschlagnahmungen würden mehr
wirkung zeigen in den folgetagen gab das
weniger stoff auf der straße heute ist
das nicht mehr der fall
es gelang zu viel kokain in die schweiz
es gibt zu viele grossisten und klein
wir können kaum noch etwas bewirken auch
nach einer beschlagnahmung rennen die
abhängigen hinter den dealern er
wir haben irgendwie resigniert gedenken
zwar nicht ständig dass wir den
genfersee mit dem löffel ausschöpfen
aber wir wissen dass unsere arbeit
ziemlich nutzlos ist wir können den
drogen verkehr nicht unterbinden
wir können einzig schauen dass das ganze
nicht vollständig aus dem ruder läuft
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob du den süchtigen vor
der kirche siehst den schwarzen mit der
kapuze
sven ist da noch ein typ mit grauer
mütze sind zugedröhnt wir auf einem sehr
mit der schwarzen mütze ist total zu
während der kokainhandel explodiert
taucht auch ein alt bekanntes produkt
wieder auf heroin seit dem arabischen
frühling sind neue dealer auf dem markt
die fahnder observieren die
drogenabhängigen
denn die dealer sind meistens nicht weit
weg läuft arbeiten drogenabhängige
meistens frauen für die araber vor allem
die nordafrikanischen dealer profitieren
davon
die süchtigen verkaufen stoff ist und
die dealer kassieren ab die abhängigen
bekommen so ihre dosis oft werden die
süchtigen zum dealen gezwungen wir haben
einige aussagen von konsumenten die
gezwungen wurden drogen zu verkaufen oft
für die nordafrikaner da die abhängigen
frauen verletzliche sind versuchen die
polizisten vergewaltigungen zu
verhindern eine stunde später wird eine
drogenabhängige verhaftet und auf der
polizeistation verhört um 20 uhr 12
wurden sie nach mehreren kontakten mit
abhängigen und albern auf der plast ole
report sechs päckchen heroin erwischt
was sagen sie dazu
[Musik]
wann kamen sie auf den platz
um viertel nach zehn oder elf dann habe
ich gewartet bis drei personen auf mich
zukamen und fragten ob ich heroin
verkauft woher kommt die ware wie kommen
sie dazu ich rufe sie an und wir
vereinbaren die übergabe wählen sie
anrufen sprechen sie da französisch ich
rufe nicht an ich schicke eine sms
sie haben die nummer bestimmt
gespeichert wir geben sie mir
netterweise da hingehe ich normalerweise
für den eigengebrauch markus jede woche
einmal pro woche und ein guter rhythmus
sie weigern sich nicht mehr die nummer
zu geben
nein sie würden mich ja sowieso dazu
zwingen
wieder sind die fahnder unterwegs
diesmal geht es zu einem informanten
viel ist den polizisten darüber nicht zu
entlocken
wir haben einen hinweis bekommen dass
ein albaner in einem öffentlichen park 5
gramm heroin päckchen verkauft sie
versuchen ihn in flagranti zu erwischen
eine nummer ein hinweis und schon haben
sie denn dealer im visier
er wurde am vorabend observiert ich
denke ja er ist es was mich raus
ich schnappe mir den kerl
[Musik]
er hatte eine kapuze auf der
polizeistation müssen die kunden in
einer gegenüberstellung ihrer
lieferanten identifizieren
je mehr kunden und stoff desto mehr
gefängnis bekommt der dealer aufgepumpt
wir setzen ihm seine mütze auf und einen
grauen rucksack
ja das ist er wir haben ihn mit mütze
ohne mütze
das macht einen unterschied auf dem
drogen dezernat herrscht hochbetrieb
während von einem dealer fingerabdrücke
genommen werden identifiziert ein vater
dessen klient in einem anderen büro wie
theorien inspiziert das eine marokkaner
abgesagt wurde
das ist sehr kompakt
da drin sind 56 solche dosen werden an
leute verkauft die kein geld haben und
sich nicht fünf gramm aufs mal leisten
kann
sie kaufen diese päckchen abhängige die
sich fünf gramm päckchen leisten können
machen daraus diese kleinste dosen
so haben sie ihre investition schnell
einmal amortisiert wie viele sind es 80
genau
[Musik]
das hier sind drogen die wir kürzlich
während einer verhandlung beschlagnahmt
haben es für uns es ist ungefähr ein
kilo heroin
du siehst und hier ein kilo streckmittel
das ding dazu die ware zu verdoppeln
oder zu verdreifachen
ich denke das ist ein tropfen verglichen
mit der menge heroin und kokain die in
der schweiz gehandelt wird
aber so ein coup gelingt uns nicht jeden
tag
es ist ermutigend für uns wenn wir so
viel beschlagnahmen können auch wenn es
nur die spitze des eisbergs ist
wir tun etwas und ein solches resultat
ist doch interessant
ich denke ein wenig schon
seine ausbeute verzögert ein erfahren
dann gibt es noch die synthetischen
drogen
für diese hochgiftigen bonbons sind in
der schweiz die strafen viel weniger
hoch als für kokain oder heroin leicht
zu bekommen nicht teuer
die party drogen sind das stiefkind der
fahnder
das problem ist dass unser erster fokus
der straßendeal ist die beschäftigung
mit solchen drogen ist eigentlich
verlorene zeit viel arbeit für praktisch
nichts
aber ich denke diese produkte werden zu
nehmen die preise werden sinken die
herstellungskosten sind sehr kleine die
gewinnmarge ist groß die drogen sind
cool und schmecken sie sind weit weg vom
image des abhängigen der an der nadel
hängt und voller blut ist das ist eine
saubere sache und sie sehen wie bonbons
aus in den usa ist das hauptproblem der
öffentlichen gesundheit die droge
crystal meth sechsmal weniger teuer und
zehn mal wirksamer als kokain und auch
viel zerstörerischer ausfall der zähne
zersetzung der schleimhäute degeneration
des gehirns
für mich ist crystal meth die schlimmste
droge
da werden bald mal ein paar soziale
bomben hochgehen die schweiz ist für
dealer ein eldorado geworden weil die
sanktionen lächerlich sind und kaum
jemanden abschrecken
alle fahren da sagen das gleiche
wenn sie den drogenhandel nicht
kontrollieren würden wäre es noch
schlimmer
doch es braucht eine große portion
selbstlosigkeit und bei der
drogenpolizei zu arbeiten
wir müssen diesen kampf führen also tun
wir es und wir haben gute gründe dafür
da gibt es keine zweifel was mich
motiviert ist dass ich etwas für die
gesellschaft tun kann mit police vor als
polizist braucht man ein soziales
gewissen und ein ideal das haben wir
eigentlich alle
ich bin noch gleich motiviert wie bei
meiner ersten patrouille projekt so
intakt wie du übernimmst die küche und
das bad zu den strand
ich denke am wichtigsten ist dass wir
das terrain nicht aufgeben wir müssen
trotz der wenigen erfolge zeigen dass
die polizei präsent ist und dass er sein
gesetz gibt er drogen kauft in verkauf
macht etwas illegales von dessous
illegal
das ist das wichtigste wir dürfen unser
terra nicht aufklären
das wäre der anfang vom ende wir müssen
unser terrain verteidigen und unsere
leute motivieren dran zu bleiben und
wenn möglich andere wege der
drogenbekämpfung finden die über die
repression hinausgehen wurde reflexion
connex als der depression die zwei
monate mit den fahndern haben gezeigt
sie können den drogenhandel eindämmen
mehr nicht ihre aufgabe ist denn auch
die bekämpfung des problems nicht dessen
ursachen doch genau dort braucht es neue
lösungen
das ist die große herausforderung für
unsere politik und unsere gesellschaft
[Musik]
dort wurde ihnen präsentiert von anda